Western Ukraine...
So I've heard of it since pretty much
day one in this country, in Ukraine.
Everyone says
"Western Ukraine, Western Ukraine,
you have to see this part of the country."
So finally... Finally...
♪ upbeat jazz ♪
[splash]
[music fades]
Getting into Ivano-Frankivsk...
First impressions...
It felt relaxed.
It felt sort of like a mellow small city.
It was Sunday morning.
Didn't spend too much time there,
we went south
through these flat lands.
Felt nice to be in a car and cruising
and then the hills
started to come into the view.
The trees started to come up around us
and it started to feel
really cool being in nature.
♪ mellow organ ♪
[church bells and birds chirping]
[organ continues]
[horse trotting by]
One of the first observations
in the Carpathians were all the churches.
I don't know for sure
but it seems from the outside...
It seems more religious.
It's Greek Catholic.
So less of the orthodox.
Ukrainians know this obviously
but for outsiders
it's like a big shift in the religion.
♪ Eurodance ♪
And then got to our first place
and our first place
was this beautiful house
that this family owned
and
we stayed there for a couple days.
So we did this hike...
Babe, what was the name of the hike?
Hoverla?
Hoverla, the highest peak in Ukraine.
I heard it's gonna rain.
So we're prepared with...
Well, all this.
[laughing]
You must be well-trained
hiking in Kyiv every day, right?
NATALIA: Oh, yeah.
NATALIA: What have you got?
Well, the essentials, obviously.
Chocolate, chocolate, and then...
Peanuts.
NATALIA: Very, very salty.
<These are salty peanuts
to eat with the beer.
We want salt 'cause we're gonna be...
NATALIA: It's to eat with the beer, babe.
[giggles]
No beer, okay, let's go.
♪ upbeat electronic ♪
But you know what she said?
Don't go there.
Green is bad right now because
it's very slippery after the rain.
So we need to take
the most difficult path.
[giggling]
[stream flowing]
The rain came in pretty strong.
[rain splashing on ponchos]
[water flowing]
Couldn't see much
but nobody turned around.
Like, everyone went
and we saw everyone from a man
with a shopping bag and a cane
[chuckles] to like a four-year-old
hiking this thing.
He didn't look happy
but he was hiking it with his parents.
This is what I love about Ukraine.
All these students, right...
And they're all hanging out together
and just having a great time.
MAN: It was hard but we're here.
PETER: Yeah.
MAN: We're doing it.
In the rain
and all these families
were going for the top
and nobody seemed to mind
that they were getting soaking wet.
Then at the top it was like a...
Like a festivity, like a party.
People had champagne out
and the number one asset to the country,
in my opinion, is just that...
How society is so connected together.
NATALIA: But the way down
is always harder.
No.
Gravity... Gravity is helping.
How was that, babe?
Eventually it's always cool. [laughs]
Like when it's done?
[hands slap]
Yeah, baby.
Woo.
I think it was, what? Third day.
Went south.
So deeper into the Carpathians.
I think this is gonna pass over.
You know, couple minutes,
sun's gonna come out.
[loud river rapids]
No comment.
[truck engine]
And so it rained, it rained,
and then it rained.
Then afterwards, it rained.
It got more beautiful.
The villages were very nice.
Like really cute.
Beautiful villages.
-How's the Carpathians so far, Nana?
-Cool.
NATALIA: Cool, wet,
but green and beautiful.
I concur.
Oh, check this out.
We got a little situation up here.
♪ dance music ♪
Surprisingly for Ukraine
the roads were actually nice.
Like really smooth and new
but then
the second I said that it changed.
And... [chuckles]
It went back to what people typically
think of Ukrainian country side roads as.
[gravel crunching]
-Want one?
-Yeah.
How do the peaches taste?
NATALIA: Mmm.
Don't make a porn out of this, love.
Just tell us how they taste.
Romanian started coming
over the radio station.
[woman speaking Romanian on radio]
PETER: Is that Romanian?
NATALIA: I think that's Italian.
PETER: Romanian sounds like Italian.
And Romanian's a beautiful language.
[woman speaking on radio]
And this Romanian influence,
you can start to feel it
as you get closer to the border
and the people look a bit different
and it feels like
a different Ukraine actually.
Look the Carpathians...
For me, feel like a much different Ukraine
than from what I've seen.
Like the Far East
where I lived last summer and here...
Two different worlds.
I like 'em both
but completely different.
Nana is having an existential crisis
and we haven't been able
to find a pee place
and this doesn't suffice.
What about right there, love?
[Natalia scoffs and giggles]
No.
PETER: Do you wish you took a pee
30 minutes ago at that spot
that we pulled over to?
Yes.
[Peter chuckling]
♪ mellow electronic ♪
The borders are weird
depending on the countries in the world.
There's always a lot of
dark sh*t happening.
And under the surface...
Like something's getting...
You know...
Someone's making a lot of money
doing illegal activity most likely.
That's the story. Who cares?
It was just interesting to see...
[chuckles]
These mansions...
And like a lot of them, incomplete
but there are a lot of big houses.
And look, this town had nothing.
There was nothing here
other than a border.
There wasn't any industry.
No cities around, nothing.
And so it was like
big house, big house, big house.
It was a last minute decision
to take a left and go park the car
and walk into Romania.
In the last bit of the journey here
on the road trip has felt like
we've been in a different country.
It hasn't felt like Ukraine at all.
Walked over the border
and Romania just felt totally different.
Like...
It felt more Italian.
Some of these...
The language obviously
and some of the architecture.
Little bit of the architecture.
PETER: Doesn't look like much is going on
in this town we don't know the name of.
The beauty of road tripping is you just...
If you leave it open enough you can just
take on these little adventures like this.
And we're just gonna be in Romania
for about an hour.
-My first time, your first time.
-Yeah.
PETER: And then get back into
the Ukrainian Carpathians.
Which feel, to me,
much more special than this place.
So we just cruised around there
for like a couple hours.
And that was right on the border, right?
So we cruised away and we got
to our second place we were gonna stay.
♪ peaceful piano ♪
Road inoperable.
And this guy Vitali
owns this place up the hill.
He built it with his family.
It overlooks a valley in the mountains
and he's an interesting character.
He's like this super-authentic nature man.
He runs 30 to 50 kilometers a day.
Something insane like that.
Doesn't really sleep.
I don't think he likes sleep.
I don't think he really eats much
but this is like
passion and soul he's put into it
and that's the thing about money.
You cannot buy that.
You can stay at the nicest
five star accommodation
but you're not gonna get
that person just giving all he's got.
Vitali's chai.
His tea.
PETER: Special...
VITALI: Black tea.
[chuckling]
Special tea from the forest.
So two places we've stayed at
people are loving what they're doing
and they put a lot into it and it shows.
Yesterday he took us on this hike.
♪ peaceful piano ♪
Beautiful hike overlooking the valleys.
It's not these mind blowing peaks.
It's not...
It's not the Himalaya or the Kackars
or the Alps
but it's a special place.
It's got a lot of depth to it.
A lot of people living for the summer
picking blueberries
and these little red berries.
I don't even know what they are.
[music intensifies]
[music fades]
♪ upbeat Ukrainian dance ♪
Word has it Vitali's got some new shoes
here at Noha Posta.
Very good brand.
PETER: Oh.
So Vitali gets these shoes
for free from Scarpa
because he's such a bad*ss on the trails.
[leaves rustling and footsteps]
VITALI: Good work.
NATALIA: He will miss us.
PETER: That's what this country offers.
That's what it really...
The true...
The true asset
of here
underneath it all
no matter
what the surface is like.
There's like this...
This depth.
And I get it, there's a dark side too
but there's a very light
human, beautiful side to it.
That's nice to connect into.
♪ peaceful piano ♪
[claps]
That's the story.
And I'll have to come back
and do some more
because that was just...
A scratch...
On the surface.
Okay.
To be continued.
[music fades]
That's last one was good enough
but if I can do better on this one
then I'll use this one.
PETER: Okay?
MAN: Okay.
PETER: Okay, okay.
Okay.
Thank you so much for watching this.
Means a lot to me.
I'm putting my heart and my soul
and my energy into making these videos
and all the content I'm doing.
So if you like it
please subscribe
and if you really like it
tell your friends
because got a lot more coming.
Thank you.
Peace.